Imagine if you were to have an
intelligentsheet that can self-fold
into any form it wants, anytime.
And that's what I've beenworking on.
And I call this robotic origami,
"robogami."
Ten years later, with my group of
ninja origami robotic researchers --
we have a new generation of robogamis.
Thisone actually navigates through
different terrains autonomously.
So when it's a dry and flat land,it crawls.
And if it meets sudden rough
terrain, it starts rolling.
It's the samerobot -- but depending
on which terrain it meets,
it activates a different sequence
of actuatorsthat's on board.
And once it meets an obstacle,
it jumps over it.
It does this bystoring energy in
each of its legs and releasing it
and catapultinglike a slingshot.
For robogamis, there's no
one fixed shape nor task.
They cantransform into
anything, anywhere, anytime.